chapter 19 is on constrained
nonlinear least squares so this is where
we
use we have not only nonlinear least
squares but we also have equality
constraints
this time they're not going to be linear
equality constraints as they are
in linearly constrained least squares
they're going to be non-linear equality
constraints
okay so let's see what the problem is
well it's going to look like this
we're supposed to minimize uh this is uh
norm there we go this is norm
f of x squared or f is the
vector and then subject to we have
p equality constraints but these are
equality constraints with possibly
non-affine functions gi and we refer to
gi
of x equals zero as the i scalar
equality constraint
so in vector notation it's just this
problem right here
a lot is being hidden there
here f is a vector so that's a sum of
squares g
is a vector also a p vector and so
that's a set of p
scalar equations uh scalar equality
constraints or equations that have to
be satisfied so we say that x is
feasible
if g of x is zero um and it's a
x is a solution or x hat is a solution
if it's feasible that's required
and if for any other feasible point it
has
an objective that is at least as big as
our point x hat
now in general this is very difficult to
solve if you mean actually literally
finding
a solution that you know is a solution
but
as with nonlinear least squares there
are very good heuristics that solve it
quite well and they solve it well enough
to be very useful in practice
again it's very much like k-means um
it's not like qr
right the qr factorization that is not a
heuristic it just works
period um or you know when we solve uh
linearly constrained least squares
problems
that is not a heuristic we simply get
the solution
period um here we have an algorithm that
uh you know might get the solution might
not which sounds kind of weird but in
fact it's
if it's useful that's uh that that's
good and in many cases it's very useful
so the lagrangian of the problem so what
we'll do is we're going to work out the
um
optimality conditions uh for the
constrained
nonlinear you know constrained nonlinear
least squares
and so the lagrangian is obtained this
way you take the objective
which is going to be norm f of x squared
and what you do is you
form you add you take so-called lagrange
multipliers these are numbers
z1 through z m
zp this should be p actually here so
that's a mistake
there you go through zp and what we do
is we
multiply each of our of our constraint
functions
by zi and we add that up and so this
becomes the lagrangian and you can write
it in very compact
vector and matrix notation i guess just
vector here
um this way as the norm squared of f of
x
plus g of x transpose z and z is this
vector of lagrange multipliers
now what the method of lagrange
multipliers tells us this is from
calculus
is that if x hat is a solution
then it has to there has to be a set of
lagrange multipliers z hat that
satisfies the following the partial
derivative of this lagrangian with
respect to x hat
x i is zero and the partial derivative
with respect to z
i is zero um and this is
there are some technical conditions
which i don't intend to get into and uh
but i don't even think we have to worry
about it now in this case you would say
that
when you find an x hat that satisfies
this and a z hat
z hat is called an optimal lagrange
multiplier so
it actually has an interpretation but
it's not one that we're going to worry
about
in this course so that's it now i should
mention
that there are points that satisfy
these conditions which are not
the optimal point that's the same as uh
non-linear least squares
the same same story
so the to work out what these two
gradients
are so that's the partial the gradient
of l with respect to x and the gradient
of l respect to z
we can work that out so the gradient
with respect to x
is that's actually the same calculation
as in nonlinear least squares and you
get twice
two times that's the jacobian or
derivative matrix
of f at x hat transpose f of x
plus and then so this is what you would
see in the case
of nonlinear least squares but here
there's an extra term
which is the derivative of g or the
jacobian of g
of x hat transpose z hat um
the gradient with respect to z so that
would be
how do you take the gradient of the well
look it's a pretty simple function in z
right it it just is z it just simply uh
there's a
it's this one right here so in fact the
gradient is g
directly so the second set of conditions
in the method of lagrange multipliers
tells us that g of x hat is zero
now truthfully we knew that already
because this simply says
x hat is feasible doesn't say anything
else but this is the other condition
and um and you can actually it's it's
good
to make sure that this generalizes
correctly non-linear least squares so
if there's no constraints you just
remove this and you remove that
and sure enough we're back to uh that's
the optimality condition for nonlinear
least squares
okay now again i'll say this this
condition is necessary for optimality
but it's not
it but it's but it's not sufficient
there are points that can satisfy this
but they're not optimal
okay let's look at constrained linear
least squares um
as a special case so here's the problem
looks like that
and then what we do is this is the same
as the non-linear problem but we set
f f to be ax minus b and g of x to be c
x minus d so in that case
f and g are both affine functions um
when you apply i mean i can tell you
what d f is d
f is a literally the matrix a it's
constant
dg is c so when you translate that to
our optimality conditions given in the
general case right here
here's what you're going to get uh you
it's this thing that's equal to 0 and
it's that
and you look at these closely and you
realize like oh that these are exactly
the kkt equations for the linear
constrained least squares problem here
and of course we assemble those
typically into a matrix that looks like
that matrix equation and you'll
recognize the
the so-called kkt matrix here on the
left and
so in the case of linearly squares
problems you simply solve that set of
equations
and you have your solution you also have
the optimal lagrange multiplier z hat
there are applications where you'd want
it but as far as we're concerned or at
least in the scope of this course we
don't have to worry about that
what we're going to do now is look at a
simple very simple method
for approximately solving the
uh non-linear constrained least squares
problem
and so we'll look at that and then i i
should tell you that this is actually
the precursor to the method we're
actually going to suggest
it's a this is going to be a so-called
penalty method
um very simple idea and what we'll do is
it's got to draw back and we're going to
come back
and and fix that drawback with a
variation on this method which is called
the augmented lagrangian method
and that will consider in the next
section but for now we're just going to
look at a simple method
so here it is um actually it's
we're instead of a constrained problem
we're going to think of it as
a what we're going to do is think of the
problem as
a bi-criterion problem and we're going
to think
of mu as going to infinity or something
like that
right because i mean if you think about
it if you were able to solve this
problem
for mu larger and larger and larger
that's going to become a solution of the
of the constrained least squares problem
because
when mu gets really big you're basically
saying
that you have no choice but to make g of
x equal to zero and that's what we want
so now this is itself a constrained
least squares problem
like that so it's just that uh depending
on
the value of mu and we could use
levenberg markquart to minimize that and
so that looks like this
i take an increasing sequence of the
muse like
mu one equals you know one then two then
four
eight sixteen that's something doesn't
matter
and what i'll do is i'll compute xk plus
one by minimizing this
using levenberg mark part but here's an
important part i'm actually going to
start at the previous point
that's important actually that's called
warm start by the way instead of cold
start
cold start starts with x equals zero or
x equals some random vector but we're
going to start with the previous one
and we'll see how that actually lends us
an advantage
soon okay so
let's take a look at this and see how
this method
uh works by the way this method works
okay
it's just not so bad i mean one minor
problem is that you might get really big
and you might have some big gradients
and things like that flying around
but it actually kind of works we'll see
another method that doesn't suffer from
that but
for now we'll look at this one okay
so the remember that for the constrained
nonlinear leak the constrained
non-linear least squares problem the
termination condition the optimality
condition is this
okay now let's suppose
uh that what we do is instead of solving
the original problem we solve
this one but for a given mu k
okay well if i do that i just write down
the optimality conditions for
for these optimality conditions for this
nonlinear least squares problem
and that's going to turn out to be
exactly this that that is the optimality
condition
okay now what we're curious about
is how does this relate to that we have
intuition that tells us that
when mu k gets really big this gets
closer this gets close to a solution of
that
but if we stare at it long enough you
realize hey
look at this um if we take
uh the following if i put this two mu k
together with the g
x k we see that this is d g of x k
transpose and then times this thing
times that that's a scalar so we can
move inside
um so i'm simply going to define z k to
be this thing
right and in that case we'll say that
that this algorithm
produces a sequence xk and zk
and this holds and that's
really kind of cool right it says that
it says that um reproduce remember that
you have
two conditions uh to term optimality
condition for the original problem right
it's this one right some people call
that the dual condition
they have lots of names and this is
called the primal condition or
it simply says that the point is
feasible right so this says that that
first one we get for free
this is completely free we get a z well
with this zk
uh it comes for free and so the only
thing we really have to worry about then
in this algorithm is that one is
becoming feasible
so people would say that with this
penalty method quote
it converges to feasibility so as the
algorithm runs
you get closer and closer to having a
feasible point
but when you have a feasible point you
have a point that satisfies the
optimality conditions
um okay so that's the idea and so you
stop the penalty method
when the norm of g of x is sufficiently
small
now of course that alone just tells you
you've you've found an almost feasible
point
but the this thing because of the way
we've constructed it this guarantees
that in fact the other condition holds
which is kind of cool for an appropriate
choice of
z okay
let's look at an example um it's
completely made up but here it is
it's f of x one and x two two variables
is gonna be you know x one plus e to the
minus x two and then some quadratic x
one squared plus two x two plus one
right
and here's g of x it's just one it's one
equation so p
is equal to one and it basically says
you know minimize the norm squared of
this expression
subject to this equation equaling 0.
now that's going to trace out a curve in
in the plane in the x1 x2 plane
let's take a look at that here's x1 and
here's x2 this
dashed curve right here is the feasible
set
right that's the point where this
equation
this is equal to that nothing is equal
to zero and that equation holds
okay um the these things these level
curves here
right these tell you the level the
they're the level sets
of norm f of x squared right
and so what we really want to do these
these are large values
up here these are getting smaller and
smaller and so along this line
this curve which is feasible we want to
find the point that has the smallest
value here
and that's actually right here that's x
hat that's going to be your smallest
value so that's the
that's the picture of of what this looks
like
okay so let's see how our penalty method
works
on this problem we'll take mu 1 equals 1
and what we'll do is we'll gen
we'll find x2 right here
then when we say mu2 equals two
um what you're going to get so here
these uh the curves
the solid curves are the um are the
contour lines
of of actually the the objective plus mu
k
times g of x squared right so we're
approximately minimizing it
um this dashed line here shows you the
feasible points
and in fact all we need is for the point
we're calculating
to be on that feasible set that tells us
that we're feasible
so at least we can do this at least
visually with
some of these things so okay so here we
get this point um
then on the next step you can see
actually that these curves have changed
because mu k
has gone up and our with the point we
compute is closer
here by the time it's four you're closer
still and if you fast forward up to 30
up to mu on the sixth step mu is 32
you can see that you're pretty close
that you're getting pretty close here
and it's actually f
it appears to be converging to the
solution it is actually
so the convergence for this looks
something like this here's the number of
uh oh and i should say what the
iterations are
the unit of effort is actually carrying
out a levenberg marquardt
iteration that means calculating the
derivative
of d and of g number one and number two
um actually solving a least squares
problem so there might be like you know
15 ludenberg marquardt iteration you
know uh
iterations for one of one outer
iteration
in the penalty method and so we actually
keep track of
the number of levenberg marquardt
iterations and we're plotting two things
here
uh the feasibility uh and um that's the
the feasibility here
and the op and then the so-called
optimality one
so the blue curve shows you the norm of
g of x and when that goes to zero
when that gets to zero that means you're
feasible right so you can see down here
ten to the minus four is you know we're
gonna call that close enough
um the red curve shows the
norm of this thing and so
that becomes zero basically after the
first
levenberg marquardt cycle is here and it
stays small
and you can see that's kind of the point
and then when both are less than i
suppose my
condition here for terminating is ten to
the minus four but when both get to be
less than ten minus four
we quit and we consider we declare
success
okay uh here's here's the value of that
uh
penalty parameter right the first q the
first levenberg marquardt
cycle takes 50 some odd iterations okay
and that lands you here then you're one
then it jumps up to two
then four then so on and that shows you
how this works and
one thing you might be concerned about
is by the end here our
mu is 10 to the four um
so well maybe you're not concerned about
that but that's the uh
that's how that works is that that
parameter gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and it kind of makes sense
so that is the that's the idea behind
this so-called penalty method